nancy geht gerade auch toilette ich
dachte sie wird jetzt kontrollieren ob
sie schwanger ist es ist zurück meine
damen und herren nach fast einem halben
jahr spiele ich nun heute wieder sims 4
und das ist eine nackte nennt wir
befinden uns hier mal wieder auf unserem
schönen grundstück wird immer noch ein
penis das ganze hier ziert sie haben
hier einen schönen pinken baum wir haben
hier andere bäume die nicht pink sind
und ich meine von all diesen sachen
wirklich nicht zu vergessen unser
riesiger springbrunnen vor groß wenn wir
uns das thema dran schauen sehen wir
schon hier ist luca meine damen und
herren der hauptdarsteller in diesem
schauspiel stück er frisst einen burger
der tatsächlich schon sehr alt ist mal
schauen wer ihm schmeckt er geht einfach
wieder weg luca und nennt sie in der
letzten folge falls euch daran erinnern
könnt die bögen sich in der letzten
folge war es so dass die beiden
tatsächlich sex hatten und leicht kriege
ich ein kind ich bin mir da noch nicht
ganz sicher allerdings ist das ziel der
heutigen folge dass wir für luca eine
freundin finden also wir haben in der
letzten folge erfahren dass hier nancy
und luca + nancy wissens freunde nennt
sie was ist denn jetzt gerade passiert
wer mit der letzten folge erfahren dass
nancy verheiratet ist und deswegen
müssen wir was wir können wenn man hier
an dem fakt jetzt hab ich das gecancelt
hier da nennen sie leider verheiratet
ist können wir wahrscheinlich nicht ihr
freund werden das ist allerdings heute
der fall kann ich eigentlich hin man
messer nehmen und die abstechen oder so
ok leute das ahnt jetzt nicht was gerade
passiert ist uns war ich habe ich auf
nancy drauf geklickt und auf einmal
steht die überzeugen ehe partner zu
verlassen
wir kriegen jetzt einfach mal auf
überzeugen ehe partner zu verlassen das
heißt jetzt ist hier er redet von
handschellen ich stelle mal wieder die
unterhaltung nach ich denke an ein
gelbes her
ich denke an eine blume die ich gleich
auffressen werde wieso geht luca jetzt
weg ich weiß nicht was jetzt gerade
passiert ist oder was nancy da hinten im
bad macht die wir stehen nämlich gerade
die hände aber ich will einfach nur dass
sie bitten zu gehen einen kurs tauchen
ich muss los danke dass du dir zeit
genommen hast warum denn alter ich
dachte ihr seid jetzt irgendwie ein
pärchen oder so hört auf zu trinken die
geräte jetzt mal hier mit der nancy
überzeugt die mainzer so ein bisschen
ein luca falsch herum ich hatte mal
einen karton auf dem kopf und dann ja
das ist ja da kann man sich erst mal
wissen ja da hatte ich einen staubsauger
und habe mir gedacht ich habe jetzt ein
staubsauger den da habe ich dann in den
panzer verwandelt panzer sind cool als
staubsauger ja ja genau das stimmt genau
so sieht doch aus wie ein staubsauger
panzer das hier ist eine statue ein
monument was ich letztens im museum
gesehen habe genau zu dosieren bin ich
damals mit mountainbiken gefahren sagt
man ein kind her ist toll hier eine cd
die ist heiß wie die sonne
was aber ich habe eigentlich lasse eine
leiter freunde wenn ihr wollt dass sich
mercedes tirol lade und bei
meine damen und herren kommen heute noch
ein zweiter teil etf alter der
wittlicher um likes und die nennt sich
mit direct alleingelassen bei der
schweizer captain muss okay ich meine
lukas ist komplett normal wie nancy
wollte eigentlich schon vor langer zeit
gehen allerdings habe ich sie jetzt
wirklich davon abgehalten
sie ist jetzt hier gerade und sie schaut
das neueste kundschafter video
wahrscheinlich hat sich auch in nyc
gelassen im gegensatz zu euch also macht
das jetzt mal verdammte scheiße alter
soll ich euch jetzt zwingen oder was
kann man da lässt man die hier wieder
einen augenblick aus den augen und nennt
sie macht hier direkt was macht sie denn
jetzt hier macht die den abwasch oder
war es halt habe okay wenn sie jetzt
spürt ist die traumfrau sie nancy allah
view sie steht jetzt in der nancy nancy
metz nancy wohin ich dachte du wärst du
trauen vor weil er spielen wollte aber
jetzt setzte sich wieder am pc und was
machst du am pc setzt sie steht wieder
auf
ich mal ein beschweren kann ich mich da
normalerweise eher weniger wir gehen
jetzt einfach mal hin und stellen eine
schlüpfrige frage spüren jetzt mal
wieder so ein bisschen fordert dass sie
so ein bisschen schneller geht die
beiden stehen jetzt hier im schlafzimmer
und unterhalten sich und ich würde sagen
dann können wir auch mal ein baby war
ich habe letztens trainiert mit
handschellen alter deswegen habe ich
auch so dicke brüste meiner haare und
jetzt geht ihr wohin und jetzt was macht
jetzt ja und ich sitze jetzt single von
meinem computer fan pages seit ich jetzt
wirklich mega bock drauf ich habe gerade
das us-car am computer da mega bock
drauf savage ist nicht mein ding ich mag
ich an fastfood so ein bisschen eine
mülltonne das ist auf jeden fall auch
das worauf ich stehe da würde ich dann
fast ohne mich reinschmeißen lass uns
noch mal zusammen videospiele spielen
ich bin eher so der künstlerische typ
nancy da schreibe ich nämlich lieber was
und bin halt mehr so künstlerisch ich
spiele gerne baseball sieht man auch ich
haben viel größeren bizeps als die lucas
zellmer jets gehen wir gar nicht mehr
aus dem kopf die unterhalten sich jetzt
gerade darüber was die denn jetzt machen
können jetzt feiern die hier sie feiert
das geld er feiert das herz sie macht
nur ein baby mit mir weil sie geld will
beiden gehen ins bett meine damen und
herren sie gehen unter die bettdecke und
[Musik]
luca you can't make it in ewigkeit
später ich habe jetzt einfach mal die
zeit wieder angehalten
wir schauen wo luca ist natürlich in der
badewanne ganz allein wir müssen die
ganze situation jetzt war eben
zusammenfassen also wir lagen gerade mit
nancy im bett lance die freundin ist
beschied die sind so nancy lancy die
sind so dicke miteinander lang auf den
fall im bett und haben jetzt ein kind
gemacht und anstatt das jetzt irgendwie
sagen okay ja wir fahren jetzt
vielleicht ins krankenhaus und
kontrolliert dass marder so luca geht
erst mal dein baden und nancy keine
ahnung wo die ist also lukas ott am pc
da vorne
nancy ist nicht bei uns im haus auch
nicht
ist das hier nennt sie ist das hier
nancy also wieso läuft ist es auf jeden
fall nancy ich würde mal schauen dass
wir von anderen seite man eben schauen
das ist ein typ wie läuft denn alter was
ist denn falsch mit ihm gelaufen die
kölner hier mal so ein bisschen
umschauen und schauen ob wir die nancy
irgendwo bei uns hier in der stadt
namens pizza finden also wir schauen uns
mal hier so ein bisschen um hier bei dem
schaukelpferd ist nicht hintenrum ist
die aurich was ist mit er ist gerade
einfach verschwunden hat luca nicht
irgendwie ein handy oder irgendwas womit
wir jetzt man nennt sie anrufen können
mehr auswahl job suchen programmieren
üben nein da war mir alles gar nicht
brauchen einfach scheiß telefon alter um
meine damen und herren seht her seht her
nancy ist angekommen wir kriegen jetzt
einfach mal drauf und machen einen
koketten witz immer könnt ihr alle hier
nicht vernünftig laufen alter nancy und
luca nähren sich hier wieder sich nancy
nancy luca steht doch hier vorne ich
weiß nicht was ihr gerade los ist aber
gerne doch eigentlich gerade ein baby
gemacht nennt sie also was macht
eigentlich keinen sinn dass du hast doch
was ist überhaupt los mit dir wieso kann
ich denn überhaupt nicht mal anklicken
hier ich klicke dazu steht die ganze
aktion du kannst das mal auf zu zocken
du gehst jetzt mal einfach zu lernen sie
hin und sie begibt sich ins bett und was
möchte man es machen will sie vielleicht
noch ein kind machen ja hier beiden wie
geht es euch unterhaltet euch
miteinander das ist ja wundervoll
jetzt tanzt ihr ein bisschen die herzen
steigen und jetzt begebt ihr euch
tatsächlich wieder in das ipad so wie
ich das beurteilen kann genau was
passiert jetzt ja freunde wir haben
gerade das zweite baby in einer folge
gemacht
ich weiß jetzt nicht wie wann das kind
irgendwie geboren wird oder sowas kugel
jetzt einfach mal wie lange es dauert
bis ein baby geboren ist also sims 4 so
machen sie ein baby klicken sie auf das
doppelbett ob es tatsächlich nachwuchs
gibt nachwuchs gibt kann der weibliches
team mit einem klick auf die toilette
testen dort hat ihm die möglichkeit
einen schwangerschaftstest zu machen es
ist jetzt allerdings gerade schon halb
elf abends das heißt du kb gibt es jetzt
einfach mal ins bett die beiden schlafen
jetzt und wir sehen schon hier unten die
zeit schreitet voran meine damen und
herren nancy geht gerade auch toilette
ich dachte sie wird jetzt kontrollieren
ob sie schwanger ist sie gehen halt auf
der website davon aus dass man ein kind
macht mit einer person die man quasi
selber erstellt hat aber ich weiß nicht
wie ich das band
kontrollieren soll ob die jetzt
schwanger als jetzt wäre halt übels geil
zu sehen wie so ein kind aussehen würde
von luca und nancy wo läuft luca hier
gerade eigentlich in lucka es 34 mitten
in der nacht wo begibst du dich gerade
natürlich zum kühlschrank ein neuer tag
angebrochen meine damen und herren ist
es halb acht morgens ich werde jetzt
einfach mal die nancy fragen ob wir denn
zusammen wo ist das denn jetzt hier man
ich war gerade auf toilette ich habe
richtig gut gekotzt die letzten acht da
habe ich dich nämlich nicht gesehen
und deswegen musste ich dann halt auch
kurzfristig nicht gesehen hab fast food
davon kann das natürlich auch kommen
weil ich dich nicht gesehen habe ging es
mir halt blendend du siehst du mich echt
scheiße aus da kann ich will einfach nur
daumen runter lassen wenn ich dich sehe
regnet der himmel locker aber zeichnen
tue ich den himmel auch ganz gerne
training kann man super toll da stellen
auf dem blatt papier mit einem panzer
würde ich dich dann überfahren richtig
dann irgendwann sehen würde genauso
gelten wie die nennt sich auf jeden fall
verscheucht hier wir werden jetzt
einfach mal so ein bisschen ernster ich
habe jetzt gesagt dass luca einfach mal
der nennen sie die bewunderung
ausdrücken soll und wir steigern uns
jetzt mal da hin dass wie sie heiraten
werden irgendwie es nämlich gerade
wieder abgehauen nachdem wir 2000 jahre
miteinander geredet haben und luca ist
auf einmal beschämt also eher freunde
ich habe es probiert mit nancy
zusammenzukommen ich habe probiert mit
ihrem kind zu machen ich weiß nicht ob
das mit dem kind noch was wird wir
schauen mal was luca hier wieder macht
der ist natürlich antennen macht man
natürlich um 10 uhr morgens während luca
hier gerade seine bahnen schwimmt
sie schwimmt er eigentlich muss ich euch
jetzt mal ganz ehrlich um eure hilfe
bitten
ich möchte ganz gern nancy heiraten und
hätte auch ganz gern ein kind mit ihr so
für die nächste folge und dann darüber
lese in der nächsten folge danach könnte
ich dann ja vielleicht auch andere
youtuber erstellen und ihr sohn youtube
haushalt machen ich habe allerdings
keine ahnung von sims also ich kann
jetzt wirklich nicht sagen okay so geht
das dass ich sehe dass sie schwanger ist
so bekommt sie ein kind ich meine es
reicht ja schon wenn ich wie das möglich
ist dass ich irgendwie nancy steuern
kann dann kann ich ja theoretisch der
nächsten folge noch mal so ein baby
machen mit mit luca und dann kann ich ja
danach mit ihr auf toilette gehen und
sie schauen ok schwangerschaftstest die
stars kriechen kind ja nein aber bis
dahin würde ich auf jeden fall sagen
wenn euch das video gefallen aber meine
damen und herren das gerne mal ein like
da wenn ihr sims 4 feiert und das wollte
das jetzt öfter hochladen
ich bekomme in letzter zeit sehr viele
kommentare von wegen herr luca macht
doch mal wieder was hier mit kollege da
hinten im hintergrund oder mit balu oder
mit vitello oder so die sache ist
allerdings dass ich in den spielen wo
ich mit denen alles so dass alles so
inszeniert habe da kann ich nicht mehr
viel machen
nintendogs habe ich das meiste gemacht
was irgendwie möglich war akinator kann
ich nicht in jeder folge gleichen sachen
googeln und clever bot okay das kann ich
jetzt vielleicht doch noch mal ein paar
mal machen aber auch gott habe ich auch
schon alles gemacht was irgendwie geht
wenn ihr ähnliche wirklich dumme spiele
kennen wo ich echt scheiße machen kann
schreibt die mir mal bitte unten in die
kommentare dann weiß ich was ihr auf
jeden fall haben wollte auf einem kanal
und sonst will ich jetzt sagen meine
damen und herren kommen jetzt zu einer
sache auch niemanden wirklich immer wenn
man sich ein kundschafter video dann
video von luca anschaut denkt dass ich
mich die ganze zeit hält darauf freue
ich mich am meisten nämlich das ende
vom video hier können jetzt jemanden
kanal abonnieren oder hier unten meinen
job ausschenken jetzt findet ihr zwei
andere videos und wenn ihr schon
abonnent zeit könnt ihr auf die glocke
klicken dann bekommt die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]